When dividing bases, we subtract the exponents. So we have 3 to the 2 minus 4 or
3 to the negative 2. This negative exponent moves the base of 3 to the
denominator with the power of 2. So we'll have 1 over 3 squared or 1 9th. Here
I'll subtract the exponents again, f to the 5 minus 8 or f to the negative 3. We
know this f will be moved to the denominator with a positive power. So 1 over f
cubed. In both this first example and the second example, you want to think,
where did you have the higher exponent? It was in the denominator. The 3 to the
4th had the higher exponent than 3 squared. And f to the 8th had a larger
exponent than f to the 5th. If we look at expanded form, we can see that the 3's
will simplify, and we're left with 3 of the 2's in the denominator or 1 9th. The
same is true with the f's. 5 of the f's simplify to 1, and then we're left with
f cubed in the denominator. This should make sense. I have more f's in the
denominator than I do in numerator. We use a similar resoaning to figure out the
last one. We should have five more w's in the denominator than the numerator. So
I know w to the 5th is that my denominator. Now I need to figure out the other
two numbers, 8 divides into 16 and 40 so I'd be left with 2 5th. So I have 2
divided by 5 times w to the 5th. There's my last fraction. I hope you found a
lot of different ways to make sense of these exponents. There's no one way or
wrong way to figure them out. You can apply the properties of power or look at
the expanded forms to get your answers. Just be sure that it's making sense
along the way.